for more than 50 years Bond girls have
given agent double-oh-seven a run for
his money in the race to see who can be
more compelling on the big screen in
celebration of that incredible legacy
and the many actresses who've
contributed to it let's see what those
Bond girls are up to today Ursula
Andress helped set the template for Bond
girls when she appeared as honey Rider
in 1962 s dr. know the scene in which
she walks out of the ocean in a bikini
is one of the franchise's most memorable
entrances she continued acting regularly
through the 1980s most prominently in
1981 s Clash of the Titans for acting
work slowed in the 90s and she hasn't
made a film since 2005 an Italian model
and beauty queen Daniela Bianca's
biggest acting role came as Tatiana
Romanova in the second Vaughn film From
Russia With Love she retired from acting
in 1970 to marry Italian businessman
Alberto Kamel II though she has since
appeared in documentary footage
discussing her time as a Bond girl
for many honor Blackman is [ __ ] Galore
a villain who proves bonds equal and
ultimately switches sides for him in
Goldfinger is the quintessential Bond
girl
since that unforgettable rule Blackman
has continued working regularly on stage
and screen and she's also enjoyed a
singing career
her most recent acting appearance was in
an episode of you me and them in 2015 as
Jill Masterson in Goldfinger Shirley
Eaton didn't have much screen time but
her death while covered in gold paint
made her an icon after bond even
continued acting in films like the blood
of fu-manchu's before retiring in 1969
to focus on raising her two sons she
published an autobiography in 1999 and
she also enjoys painting and sculpture
Thunderball had a memorable and sexy
villain in the form of Luciana Pelosi as
Spectre agent Fiona
Volpe the resulting Fame kept her acting
throughout the 60s and 70s since 1980
she's been married to American
businessman Michael J Solomon she
doesn't have any on-screen acting
credits since then though she has given
interviews reflecting on her time as a
Bond girl Diana Rigg was already a star
by the time she appeared as Bond's bride
Tracy in 1969 on Her Majesty's Secret
Service since then she's continued to
work steadily in film TV and theatre she
became a dame in 1994 and her most
famous recent role was her Emmy
nominated turn as Queen Olenna Tyrell on
Game of Thrones Jill
John played diamond smuggler Tiffany
cases and diamonds are forever making
her the first American Bond girl she
continued acting steadily until 2002 at
which point she largely retired since
1990 she's been married to actor Robert
Wagner
her most recent screen appearance was as
mrs. Claus alongside Wagner as Santa in
the 2014 hallmark movie North Pole Jane
Seymour rocketed to worldwide fame in
1973 as the enigmatic solitaire in Roger
Moore's James Bond debut Live and Let
Die since then she's worked regularly in
both film and TV most famously as the
title character on dr. Quinn Medicine
Woman she's also an author of self
health and children's books and she
designed the open hearts collection of
jewelry for Kay Jewelers Britt Ekland
role as Miss good night in the man with
the Golden Gun cemented her status as a
sex symbol and she continued acting well
into the 80s
she was also famous for her high-profile
relationships with Peter Sellers and Rod
Stewart in the past decade she's shown
up on a few reality TV shows including
the Swedish series Let's Dance in 2018
Barbara Bach achieved fame is agent Anja
a massive ax in 1977 s The Spy Who Loved
Me she continued to act in the 80s but
she hasn't appeared in a film since to
the north of Katmandu in 1986 since 1981
she's been married to former Beatle
Ringo Starr she's also been active in
charity work forming the self-help
addiction recovery program in 1991 Lois
Child's was offered the female lead in
The Spy Who Loved Me but she was taking
a hiatus from acting at the time and
turned it down but then a couple of
years later she accepted the role of dr.
Holly Goodhead in 1979 s Moonraker she
continued acting throughout the 80s and
90s and her most recent film role was in
2006 is kettle of fish French actress
Carol bouquet achieved international
fame as the Vengeance seeking Molina
have a lock in 1981 s for your eyes only
she's continued acting in dozens of
films plays and TV series ever since in
2014 she served on the jury of the
Cannes Film Festival and in 2017 she
played a serial killer in the French
miniseries Lamont a Maude Adams is
unique among the actresses on this list
for playing two different Bond girls
first she was Andrea
in the man with the Golden Gun and then
she was the title crime lord in 1983's
Octopussy she also even had an
uncredited cameo in a view to a kill she
continued to act regularly until largely
retiring in the late 2000s Tanya Roberts
appeared as Stacey Sutton in 1985 of
view to a kill and she continued to act
regularly throughout the 90s before
landing her most famous recent role as
Donna's mother midge on that 70 show she
ultimately left the show in 2001 though
she did return for a brief run of
episodes in 2004 her acting career has
been largely inactive since then in a
view to a kill Grace Jones was instantly
memorable as the deadly Mayday she's
continued to appear sporadically in
films and TV in subsequent decades but
her major pursuit as it was before bond
is music since 1977 she's released ten
studio albums and remains one of the
most distinctive performers of her
generation in 1987 Miriam diabo kicked
off the Timothy Dalton era as caramello
V in the living daylights she's
continued to work as an actress and
model ever since in 2002 she hosted the
documentary Bond girls are forever in
2007 she suffered a near-fatal brain
hemorrhage from which she thankfully
later recovered Carey Lowell played Pam
Bouvier in 1989's
licensed to kill and she's continued to
act to this day she had a major role as
Jamie Ross on Law & Order beginning in
1996 in the mid 2010s her divorce from
Richard Gere was the subject of a
three-year legal battle as of 2018 she's
returned to TV with roles on Blue Bloods
and bull in 1995 the Pierce Brosnan era
of bond began complete with a new
Moneypenny in the form of Samantha bond
who appeared in all for Brosnan films
since the Brosnan era ended she's
continued act in a little bit of
everything
her most recent high-profile role was
Lady Rosamund Painswick on the hit
series Downton Abbey the Brosnan era
also brought with it a new female M Judi
Dench played the head of mi6 as a tough
resourceful woman who could keep bond in
his place she was so good that she
stayed on into the Daniel Craig era
until m's death in 2012 Skyfall and
since she is Dame Judi Dench her career
has kept chugging along in 2019 she will
be seen in adaptations of our
faul and cats and you get to boss him
about and um and there is a very special
relationship I think between between
bond and em Isabella's scarab CO was
already a successful model singer and
actress when she was cast as Natalya in
1995's Goldeneye her other memorable
acting work includes roles and Exorcist
the beginning and rain of fire in 2011
she returned to singing with a
collaboration with Swedish vocalist
Peter you back and in 2012 she served as
a host of Sweden's Next Topmodel fomka
Jansen achieved breakout success as
xenia onatopp in Goldeneye genocide a
gay if not on that thumb on a toe on the
top the roll rocketed her to stardom and
helped land her the role of Jean Grey in
the x-men franchise since then she's
acted regularly in the likes of taken
and Hemlock Grove she will soon be seen
in the Netflix original series Central
Park 5 Michelle Yeoh established herself
throughout the 1990s as a major player
in Hong Kong action cinema before
breaking out worldwide in 1997 Tomorrow
Never Dies in 2000 she again wowed
international audiences in Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon and has continued
big-screen success ever since most
recently in crazy rich Asians teri
hatcher appeared in Tomorrow Never Dies
as Paris Carver a former flame of Bond
who's now the trophy wife of a
villainous media mogul she was already a
TV superstar with Lois & Clark
and after bond she had another big hit
in the form of Desperate Housewives more
recently she's returned to the world of
DC Comics with a recurring role on the
CW's Supergirl Denise Richards was at
the height of her fame when she played
Christmas Jones in 1999 the world is not
enough since then she's continued to
appear in plenty of films and taken on a
career as a reality TV personality she
starred in her own series Denise
Richards it's complicated and in 2019
she joined the cast of The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills French
actress Sophie Marceau achieved
blockbuster success as the villainous
electric King in the world is not enough
she's continued to work steadily as an
actress writer and director ever since
in 2002 she made her feature directorial
debut with speak to me of love and in
2015 she
served on the main competition jury for
the Cannes Film Festival Oscar winner
Halle Berry was already a major star
when she played jinx in Pierce Brosnan's
final Bond film 2002's
died another day her career has suffered
a few missteps along the way but she's
rebounded and continued to work steadily
in film and TV among her most notable
projects since bond are returned to the
x-men series and Kingsman the Golden
Circle the Daniel Craig era required a
memorable Bond girl that kicked things
off and it got one with Ava green as
Vesper Lynd in Casino Royale the role
made green an international star she
since gone on to roles and the likes of
penny dreadful and miss Peregrine's Home
for peculiar children in 2019 she can be
seen in Tim Burton's live-action Dumbo
remake after a successful modeling
career ukrainian-born French actress
Olga Kurylenko landed the role of
Camille Montes in 2008 Quantum of Solace
she has since continued to earn
high-profile roles in films like
oblivion the death of Stalin and Johnny
English strikes again as of 2018 she
lives in London with her son and
boyfriend Naomi Harris was a ten-year
veteran of film acting by the time she
landed the part of the third big-screen
Moneypenny in Skyfall and she
immediately won fans over with her
portrayal she reprised the role in 2015
Spectre and has since garnered acclaim
for her work in moonlight and appeared
in major releases including rampage and
Mowgli legend of the jungle vs adieu has
been acting for more than a decade but
in many ways her career is still very
young she achieved international acclaim
in 2013 for her role in blue is the
warmest color and parlayed that into her
role as dr. Madeline Swan in 2015
Spectre she's expected to reprise her
role for the 25th Bond film in 2020
a rare repeat performance for a Bond
girl check out one of her newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]